[Musique]
votre peau il ne s'agira pas d'une
guerre de héros et nation ce massacrant
les unes les autres et nous deviendrons
rice
ça va être amusant
il
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez pas me garder enfermés
alors que le monde s'embrase
monfils le monde est gouverné
par la corruption il avidité
vont intervenir certainement
nous sommes la première agence de
renseignement indépendante raffiné mais
brutaux civilisé mais impitoyable
non
bienvenue au club c'est très malin il
est temps de verser de l'huile sur le
feu
de la révolution est mon berger
un venu l'anglais raspoutine votre
réputation vous précède
[Musique]
réglons ça entre gentlemen après tout
c'est à ces manières
anonymat
pourquoi les hommes sont ils toujours
aussi brouillon